ادلب تحديدا من سد التلول مراسل والجزيره
صهيب الخلف صهيب كنت تنقل لنا خلال هذا
اليوم مخاطر ارتفاع منسوب المياه حيث انت
وتاثيره على المناطق المجاوره كيف يتطور
المشهد وكيف يتعامل الاهالي مع هذا الخطر
في الحقيقه المشهد يتطور بشكل سلبي جدا
على حياه الحياه سكان البلده لانه وعندما
زرنا الجزء الذي انهار من السد الترابي
كانت الاجزاء كانت اجزاء اخرى من هذا السد
الترابي تنهار وتنجرف مع المياه المتدفقه
من نهر العاصي الذي طافت مياهه وارتفع
منسوبه الى مستوى غير مسبوق هنا في هذا
المنطقه وذلك بعد الزلزال الذي ضرب
المنطقه وبعد ايضا فتح النظام السوري لسد
الرستان وسط البلاد لتتدفق المياه بشكل
كبير الى هذه المنطقه وهنا في هذه المنطقه
ما تزال المياه تغمر الشوارع الرئيسيه
وتغمر الكثير من البيوت
القريه يرتفع يعني ان هذه المياه تزيد
باستمرار
لانهيار اجزاء ان اسد الترابي مع الامر
الذي يتخوف منه سكان القريه لان ذلك سوف
يعني غمر اجزاء اخرى منها ومن بيوتها ودفع
عائلات اخرى الى النزوح
للتشرد وسط اجواء الشتاء البارده فرق
الدفاع المدني السوري هنا في هذه البلده
لكن هي منقسمه بين البيوت التي دمرت
بواسطه الزلزال او
الانتشار العالقه العائلات التي ما زالت
او التي وصلت مياهه الفيضاني والنهر اليها
حاولت فرق الدفاع المدني فتحه ساقيه في
الطريق الرئيسي لتسهل انتقال المياه من
ضفه الطريق الى الضفه الاخرى لكن ذلك
اي نفع لان كميه المياه كبيره وحجم المياه
كبير وهنا في هذه وفي هذه القريه يوجد
مخيم ايضا للنازحين وصلته المياه ودفعت
العشرات من النازحين الى الانتقال الى
مناطق اعلى معلومات قبل قليل بان منظمه
انسانيه تقوم ببناء خيم جديده لهم وقد بنت
حتى الان قرابه سبعين خيمه يستطيع ان زميل
مصور ان يتجه الى البيوت ايضا
ونرى المياه كيف تتدفق بينها واكثر ما
يخاف منه سكان البلده
ان تدخل المياه الى بيوتهم التي تصدعت
بسبب الزلزال ما سوف يؤدي الى تضررها بشكل
كبير او انهيارها الكارثه تبدو اكبر من
قدرات الجميع هنا ويتحدث من التقيناهم من
سكان البلده ومن المسؤولين في المعارضه
الذين يزورونها عن ان الحل الوحيد هو فتح
المجال
لداخل الاراضي التركيه وازاله الحاجز
الاسمنتي في الحدود السوريه التركيه
لتتدفق المياه بشكل اكبر الى داخل الاراضي
التركيه ولكن ذلك قد يكون له حسابات كثيره
عند الجانب التركي قبل ان يفعل ذلك وبينما
هذا وذاك يبقى سكان البلده في خطر حقيقي
شكرا جزيلا لك حتى ساعه مراسلنا صهيب
الخلف من سد التلول